let me ask you something
what is the number one thing in in in
that you experience
in la that is like impedes or affects
your peace
every day i'm not talking about i'm
talking about
tangible things i'm talking about like
what's something
like for me it's when i drive and i see
like
full homeless people cities under the
bridges
like and i'm like yo fam like thank god
my kid don't gotta walk to school
through here because these [ __ ]
are shooting hearing on the side of the
road
and mayor garcetti is pretty much
you can't do nothing like that like like
the the police force
like literally can't do anything about
it yeah it's a whole community it's a
liquor store it's
called right so that's my example right
right so i'm like okay
those kind of things collectively you
can vote to change
yeah so what [ __ ] me because you asked
me questions so what [ __ ] me up
like what makes me feel like the most
uh when i let you like a problem is that
right but when i see
that what [ __ ] me up isn't the fact
that i can't
get them up or make them leave it's the
fact that they're there
it's the fact that like my people when i
see black people because that's who i
give my money to my right all right
when i see colored people how did you
get there it's the fact that you're
there
it's the fact that you don't own land
it's the fact that you don't even have
your 40 acres in a meal you didn't even
get to jump start with that
now whether or not you just ended here
because you [ __ ] your 40 acres off
or whatever was owed to you like the
indians get
like jews and many too many to name then
that'd be a different convo but due to
the fact that i know how our people
where we come from dog when i drive down
skid row cause
that was going to be my answer what
[ __ ] me up every day is the fact that
my
family the people i gotta do i just had
to fire my cousin off my food truck
after two weeks three weeks whatever of
trying my hardest to [ __ ]
deal with them right right wherever i
get we got those family members all day
it's literally a psychological bond
psychological bondage that we're in dog
that is like
it's not a pity party it's not me like
trying to make excuses
you know what i'm saying because he's
like that because his dad is how his
dad is and it's genetic so let me ask
residuals from american history so what
you're saying is all our residuals
are [ __ ] poison it's crack it's rape
it's incest it's [ __ ] pain is is
is trauma that's our residuals that's
the reparations we've been given we
can't get no money then [ __ ] want to
give edd
and [ __ ] that [ __ ] what is that
well listen
i think that there's no uh
what you're talking about there might
not be a uh
it's a solution no well don't go ahead
what do you think the solution is then
because i don't think that there's
a clear-cut solution yeah it is what is
it it's very clear that's what my album
talks about that's what color it is
that's what this whole [ __ ] is about
it's what it stands for
it's black ownership it's leaving a
legacy it's financial freedom
residual income that is the [ __ ]
answer
not voting what the [ __ ] listen voting
does not give you any like okay whether
you win
whether you win and voted cause y'all
gonna blame it on me y'all gonna y'all
are going to blame it on my one vote
as to why the rent went up in california
and that
in that in that price by the way y'all
gonna blame it on my one vote or me
telling my people which i reposted on my
story
those props okay but y'all but but the
people
don't blame it on me as my one vote as
to why
rent went rent king is possibly gonna go
up in california now
but guess what black man black woman if
you had ownership
if you had a company if you had
businesses you had residual income
that wouldn't be a problem to you
because i could give a [ __ ] about rent
going up in california
period so that's what i'm pushing that's
the answer because if
i had a million dollars that i can that
i can literally like
cut a check right now that wouldn't like
that wouldn't make me lose no sleep
or even if it did make me lose some
sleep but it was for my [ __ ]
people
and my cousin did and i could call my
bro bobby that does
and i could call five and ten of my
homies that got a m
we wouldn't even have to talk about all
this [ __ ] because we'd have our own
party we'd have our own political party
then it'd be established we
wouldn't have to wait on diddy lay you
to death we wouldn't have to wait on
ross we wouldn't have to wait on none of
these [ __ ]
there's no ownership bro there's no
financial freedom my sons
are going to own so i have [ __ ]